Rolex bought a meteor that landed on
Earth in 1838 and when they bought this
they said you know what let's get
creative let's make some water dolls out
of this and it's definitely one of the
most demanded dials in the world right
now
what's up GQ almost the Jeweler Jeweler
based out of New York City Diamond
District and today we're going to be
looking at Celebrities and the crazy
watches that they wear
Pharrell Williams
got a Pharrell rock and a crazy rm88 in
order to get your hands on this it comes
at a crazy price tag I believe Pharrell
did pay around 1.2 million dollars for
this piece that's a mansion almost
anywhere in the world Richard Mill
definitely has fun when he designs his
watches especially for people like
Pharrell you know Pharrell needed
something like this that's extremely
bright and that he could show off to the
people because something like this
you're not going to find on anyone's
wrist they only make 50 of these in the
world so over here you got Pharrell
wearing a
rm7402 with a automatic tourbillon
movement and of course you see Pharrell
wearing it with this gorgeous rose gold
Factory bracelet that does come from RM
and it gives it such a different look
you don't see watches with this type of
bracelet on Richard Mill knows how to
stand out it's almost impossible to make
a name for yourself in this generation
in the watch world because of course
you're going against names like Rolex
Audemars and Paddock Philippe which I've
been doing this since the 1800s but
Richard Miller really came into the game
in the early 2000s and he's the watch
that everyone wants now you have the
biggest names wearing them people are
paying the craziest price tags in the
world for these type of pieces they're
extremely limited to come across it's
the high-end G-Shock of the world now as
you can see you get this bright red look
everyone goes crazy over it I mean the
mechanism in here is just incredible
what Richard Mill did especially is he
has like that skeletonized look where
you can actually see the whole entire
movement inside you can see the balance
wheel you can see everything that's
going on in there again it's just this
Rarity that people go crazy about and
when you wear a piece like this you can
see this from a mile away this bright
red stands out crazy I know you could
get a G-Shock that's also bright red
that would run you around fifty dollars
but a piece like this could run you
close to four hundred thousand dollars
we got Pharrell wearing the rm5205
tourbillon when you see this watch you
think Pharrell Williams Because he was
the first one that got this when you
look at that enamel work that was done
in the dial you see the reflection of
the Moon from the astronauts glass and
then you have the Earth also over there
I mean to capture all this detail do
this in enamel and then put it in a
watch
unbelievable if you're a person who
appreciates watches this has to be in
your top five Pharrell's watch I believe
is the only rm52 with the astronaut that
has the Sapphire case because if you can
see the two different photos the case on
that is a metal case then the one that
Pharrell is wearing is the sapphire
crystal which is again very special very
hard to do all custom cut crystal to fit
the case extreme amounts of work and
extremely special
Jay-Z
this is the Michael Jordan of all
watches over here what we have here we
got a Jay-Z wearing a paddock Philippe
5711 Nautilus with the Tiffany blue dial
you got that Tiffany stamp on there and
uh when you're wearing this piece you're
probably gonna know the person who's
wearing it also because you can't get
your hands on this the first one was
sold in auction for six and a half
million dollars and if you want to get
one today you're going to be probably
paying a hefty price tag of over 3
million Tiffany and Paddock when they
made this watch together they said let's
make 170 pieces to represent the amount
of years since our first collaboration
so imagine Tiffany and Paddock were
working for 170 years together and
they're paying homage to the anniversary
coming out with such a unique piece that
every single person wants but
unfortunately not everyone can get Tom
Cruise we got Tom Cruise here seeing
wearing a nice Cartier Santos I got a 20
to see it playing because I've seen the
Swatch iced out more than I've seen it
plane but again very classic look you
know a very good starter piece something
that's going to run you around that six
thousand dollar ballpark it's cool to
see is somebody as big as Tom Cruise
where just such like a classic low-key
Cartier Santos stainless steel with that
white dial that goes crazy again if
you're looking for your first watch you
don't want to break the bank of course
you know some people that have budgets
of over a hundred thousands of Bunches
of ten thousand but then I get questions
every single day people ask me what can
I get I have a 4K budget 5K bunch of 6K
budget can never go wrong with a nice
vintage Rolex something back from like
the 70s a nice 36 millimeter datejust
which again iconic piece something I
will never go out of style if you want a
modern day piece you go for the Cartier
Santos like you see Tom Cruise rocking
over here you know there's watches for
every single budget and that's the
coolest part about watches you never
right or wrong buying a watch it's as
long as you enjoy it that's all that
matters
Denzel Washington it was all shout out
Denzel my hat goes off to him I love
Denzel and over here we got him wearing
a very humble piece enjoying a nice
G-Shock on his wrist so I got a nice
look to it also it got that nice little
bulky look Duffy shows out again a piece
like this this is also a gorgeous watch
to get into if you don't have that high
budget to buy yourself a Rolex or an AP
this is uh still watch I would add in my
own collection so this specific G-Shock
that Denzel is wearing goes for around
380 on the retail side there's also many
other affordable G-Shocks that will run
around like 80 to 100 some gorgeous
pieces they call it the Army watch
that's what all the soldiers wear so if
this could withstand the war we could
also withstand probably anything that
you do on your day-to-day basis
Mark Wahlberg when you're Mark Wahlberg
and you have a collection that's worth
multi millions of dollars you can come
out wear a nice Timex that probably ran
around 80 and the rocket and look uh
extremely swaggy in it too you know it's
cool to know that somebody who has so
much money is still able to wear such a
subdued piece it makes people that don't
have the crazy amount of money Rock
these type of pieces too or whatever
being such a big influencer people want
to copy his style and when you see him
wearing a Timex you say you know what
I'm gonna throw Timex on my wrist also
we also got Mark Wahlberg wearing this
extremely rare olive green dial Platinum
day-date 40. the way I could tell it's a
day date first of all is when you see
that smooth bezel with the presidential
links that's your key to know that this
is a platinum Day date when you get it
to that olive green Arabic dial
extremely rare they made a very finite
amount of this I wish Rolex did number
their pieces they don't but if this is
numbered there's probably less than 500
in the world of these and Mark Wahlberg
is uh lucky to own one of these in his
collection Fat Joe
you have your Plain Jane watches but you
also have your quintessential bus down
rapid watch Joey crack baby New York
Legend first of all actually held this
piece in person and uh wow the diamonds
in there unbelievable every stone there
was cut special every stone does have a
GI certificate on it of course when
you're a fat Joe you need to support a
piece like this to really stand out when
you wear a piece like that it's it's a
legit Chandelier on your wrist it's like
wait what is that Avi if you want to
pass me one on the house I'll uh I'll
take a pristine piece also it's a
gorgeous piece and so the cool part is
with these watches is that when it's
done Factory in-house it will retain its
value because the company that produces
the watch and sets Factory stones in it
they are willing to check on your watch
and service it in the future as opposed
to setting aftermarket diamonds in your
watch where you take a plain Jane Rolex
you start setting it Rolex will not
check your watch when your diamonds are
set by the company that makes the
factory diamonds that's the one that
normally goes up in value like Drake
said
in this watch that you see Fat Joe
wearing the pristine timepiece Avalanche
there's around 200 carats of diamonds
which is absurd it's Insanity so your
average Iced Out watch something like
this would hold around like 25 carats so
that is 10 times the amount I mean when
you see the size of those stones every
single stone that could be its own
engagement ring so uh imagine how crazy
it is
Bobby Shmurder
Bobby Shmurder crazy timepiece on his
wrist he's actually wearing two pieces I
see he's got the sky dwell on his left
wrist and the AP on his right wrist
which is gorgeous that Sky dweller he
obviously said no budget big rocks in
the vessel and then I want big rocks
going down the middle of my band which
you don't see this many times in your uh
busting down Sky dwellers he definitely
paid a hefty price for this piece you
have many different options to go with
the bus downs but at the starter price
you're looking at around 20 000 and up
for a nice big face bust down everyone
wanted the Cartier Santos size style
during pandemic that was like the one
watch I sold so many of them I can't
even count how many I saw but when you
go for a piece like that you're gonna be
looking at around that twenty thousand
dollar range and then of course you have
bus Downs like this AP that Bobby
Schmidt is wearing that kid probably ran
him like 60 70 000. so if you want to
buzz down your watch you have to
understand it's not going to be going up
in value a lot but if you do buy
correctly then you're not gonna lose so
much also you know because there is a
market for it again most of the time
when you are gonna buy an iced out watch
though you're not thinking of it being
an investment or not it's like going to
Louis Vuitton and buying uh shirts and
pants from Louis Vuitton if you try to
resell it you're not going to be getting
so much back you know but you buy it
because you enjoy it it's definitely a
flex but if you're looking to get a
watch that is a good investment and
you're not gonna lose so much money in
your best off going for a plane Jane or
a watch with Factory diamonds which uh
definitely retain its value much better
than the one with aftermarket diamonds
Drake
piece like this extremely finite amount
and of course Drake is one of the people
that do own them Drake's meteorite
Factory Diamond Sky dweller it retailed
for around half a million dollars but uh
if you wanted it today it'll set you
over a million Rolex bought a meteor
that landed on Earth in 1838 and when
they bought this they said you know what
let's get creative let's make some water
dolls out of this and it's definitely
one of the most demanded dials in the
world right now everyone's calling
saying I want the day date with the
meteorite I want the Daytona with the
meteorite and these prices are going for
way more than the regular Dial Drake
went classy kind of normal for him but
uh still an incredible piece they did 40
yellow gold with the black baguette
diamond dial one of my favorite pieces
personally we actually have it over here
to show you guys the way those baguette
hit on that black it's unbelievable you
know to have your hour markers set as
baguettes is something so unique in my
eyes always catches my attention of
course that yellow gold with the black
and the Diamonds
one of my favorite combinations in the
world this one retails for around 39 000
at Rolex and they're going for around
the same price on a secondary Market
the weekend
the weekend baby you know he's got to
have something special on his wrist he's
got a paddock Philippe 5167 Aquanaut in
stainless steel which I got this piece
right here
I love this piece first of all again
very low-key doesn't stand out so much
but it's if you know you know type piece
most of the time you would think people
pay big bucks to uh to shine and be
outlandish but now people are paying the
big bucks to be more low-key Frank Ocean
incredible piece there's so much going
on in the dial I'm like trying to figure
out where to start right now but of
course you got that tourbillon balance
wheel on the left side and I love how
you paired it you have the subdued
leather with the watch and then he put
that gorgeous white gold bracelet next
to it to give it a little more pop and
shine and I just love the way it looks
so an AP made this they made 150 pieces
but they also made 14 one of ones for
ap's highest clientele and of course one
of them is Pharrell Williams and I
believe that Frank Ocean actually bought
this in the auction from Pharrell
Williams so this is actually one of
Pharrell's pieces that uh Frank Ocean is
sporting over here
Tyler the Creator
you know somebody like Tyler he always
wants to be different when most people
are wearing the Rolexes and the Richard
Mills Tyler said you know what let me go
crazy let me buy these very rare
Cartiers and let me be different of
course when he does this a lot of people
like to follow the new trend that he has
uh created only somebody like Tyler can
really do something like this that
Cartier crash I love the way that looks
pops out you know you see that piece you
know it's uh something extremely
different you don't see watches that are
done like that Kanye sported it I know
Jay-Z has on his collection and when you
see a piece like this the first thing
you think is Mystery what did it come
from who designed it there are some
stories that people say that it was
involved in a car crash that it was in a
truck getting delivered to its Cartier
store and there was a car accident and
this is how it's got its shape a lot of
people say that it's not true the way
that it was designed is still a mystery
till today it reminds me of like
Salvador Dali when you see that free
form shape definitely not your typical
watch it's something that stands out and
it's like wait what is that I need a
closer look because it has that small
case size but it's also very different
it's like I want to see what's going on
in yours when I see that piece we got a
Tyler Creator wearing a Cartier Opus
quadrant very different piece of course
you see how much metal there is
surrounding that dial so again Cartier I
guess they like to stand out doing a
different style cases where you don't
see on most watches you know very unique
and very different and of course he's
sporting it with a gorgeous orangey
larvae style leather band stands out
it's definitely very different I don't
know if it's my cup of tea but Tyler's
wearing it gorgeously so I might have to
add one of my own collection we got a
title wearing a Cartier Pebble extremely
rare piece I'm assuming that uh Tyler
the Creator could spend close to half a
million dollars on this piece knowing
the market on these everyone wants it
but also extremely extremely rare of
course a man like Tyler needs one of his
collection needs something that's gonna
stand out and that most people cannot
get
Brianna
this was special everyone went crazy in
the Super Bowl when Rihanna wore this we
got here we got Rihanna wearing a Jacob
and Co with this bright red glass
encasing the skeletonized dial
unbelievable when it comes to Jacob and
setting stones on his watches it's the
best shout out to Jacob for making these
big icy pieces always so special I mean
the work on this it's a one of one and
when you see it you think Rihanna we're
in a piece like this you have a nearly
like 300 diamonds I know those around
like 230 Diamond set on this case and of
course you have diamonds on the crown
and on its Buckle the cool part with
Jacob is Jacob started as a jeweler
before he created watches so his
knowledge and Diamond setting and
Diamond selection you see how he brought
it over two watches when you see a Jacob
watch most of the time there will be
Diamond set in it and most of the time
it's perfect
Ben Affleck
but I again just like most of these
celebrities they want to stand out
differently he said you know what I've
been wearing Rolex for uh 20 30 years
let me uh let me give her a mess a
chance let me see if this fetches me a
couple different compliments or a couple
different questions here's Ben Affleck
and the Hermes arsolare de la lune I've
personally not seen a lot of people wear
it so together you see the contrast so
you have black in that dial and also
white so I'm assuming that it's this uh
intricate mechanism over there I believe
it is a moon phase mechanism from the
looks of it with the two moves that you
see on the dial that's done with of
course precisely caught mother of pearl
that they had to place intricately in
the dial this one costs 35 000 thank you
guys for watching I'm Melissa Jeweler
signing out